U.S defense secretary Lloyd Austin was
hoping to deliver better news to his
Ukrainian counterpart at the Ramstein
Air Base but there was to be no
commitment from Germany that it would
send its leopard tanks to Ukraine we
don't fear anything we have just a
responsibility for our population in
Germany and in Europe and we have to
balance all the pros and contracts
before the research we decide things
like that just like that this is nothing
else and I'm very sure that there will
be a decision in the short term but I
don't know why and I don't know how how
the decision will look this lack of a
concrete timeline is this by Germany's
NATO allies and Ukraine itself
pressuring hard for the tanks to be sent
I encourage you to make such decisions
that can deprive Russian evil of of any
power you can start this policy today it
is in your power to make a Rammstein of
Tanks
not to bargain about different numbers
of Tanks but to open a principled supply
that will stop Russian evil some fear
that sending leopard tanks could mean an
escalation of the war and drag NATO into
a direct confrontation with Russia
the tanks have been sold to dozens of
countries around the world those who
want to export them to Ukraine need
permission from Germany first after
weeks of international pressure Germany
has made it clear that it will take a
decision on whether or not to send leper
thanks to Ukraine in its own time
president zelenskies plea that time is
not a luxury his country has had little
effect because Germany says it's a
decision that needs to be carefully
weighed despite the setback there have
been Promises of new military hardware
for Ukraine U.S defense secretary Austin
urging countries not to waste too much
time this is a decisive decade for the
world
and this is a decisive moment for
Ukraine's struggle to defend itself
so this contact group will not slow down
we're going to continue to dig deep and
based upon the progress that we've made
today
I'm confident that Ukraine's partners
from around the globe
are determined to meet this moment
in Berlin a group of protesters also
tried to put pressure on the government
to take a decision on sending leopard
tanks sooner rather than later stepfast
and Al Jazeera at Ramstein Air Base